an intersection is permanently closing
in the northeast of Valley after several
crashes over the year including a deadly
one in September now it's located on Las
Vegas Boulevard at Sloan Lane which is
near Nellis Air Force Base well it's set
to close on November 19th Joshua baguero
Joins us live with what drivers can
expect Joshua good afternoon
how you doing good afternoon the closure
is happening at the request of Nellis
Air Force Base and as you can see beside
me there's already signage indicating
the road is being permanently closed
this danger is very dangerous and I
would like to see them to you know
correct that Martinez age says he worked
at the Bed Bath and Beyond plant along
Sloan and this road is worse at night
well I've seen a lot of close calls you
know and there's no people who's walking
and catching the bus they are really are
in danger because they do not have any
type of lighting driving along slow and
you can see a lot of construction at one
point Sloan is reduced to one lane
according to Nellis Air Force Base
installation Commander Joshua demons
safety led to the decision to close the
road you may recall back on September
23rd two people died in a two vehicle
crash in this specific area
also according to Nellis Air Force Base
Las Vegas Boulevard between Sloan Lane
and Range Road has become unsafe data
from the Nevada Department of
Transportation shows 20 crashes have
happened on Sloan and Las Vegas
Boulevard from 2016 to 2020. concerns me
is the the fataleness you know crashes
and you know people losing their lives
because people don't want to spend money
but they're going to make it
now this intersection is on the federal
property which is why Nellis Air Force
Base could close it drivers are
encouraged to instead use and Road in
Mount Hood instead reporting live near
Nellis Air Force Base Joshua baguero
eight news now
well the county is advising drivers that
detours around Sloan Lane May fluctuate
due to the construction